[Music]
welcome to another fun-filled episode of
album of the week listen this week's
album of the week we're going to keep it
in the grunge family because uh we just
went on this run we might as well keep
it on this [__] run all right so we
covered sound garden we covered never
mind we covered uh Temple of the Dog
we've covered a couple great [__]
albums and uh we still got more to cover
so the first album I heard was obviously
uh 10 you know and I like Pearl Jam and
then s garden came along Into My Life
One Way or Another and I really took the
super unknown and then I went on the
road and I got to Seattle and I used to
work at a club called Giggles in the U
District and uh there was a cute little
waitress there a little hippie chick I
used to buy weed from some rocks from
time to time whatever she had and after
every [__] show she would always go
what are you doing I go nothing she goes
do you want to go up and party out with
Allison Chains I'm like who the [__] is
Allison Chains I didn't know [__]
Allison James was I you know and you're
trying to be cool you're like I'm busy I
didn't know who the [__] Allison James
was so I asked Josh Wolf that night at
the underground I go Josh who the [__]
is Allison Chains he goes you got to
listen that they're a band that managed
by Sue Silva who used to come to the
club all the time so we know who Su
Silva was so when he told me I'm like
really I went that day and I I went I I
think uh it was one of Brody's friends
we went by uh where he lived laigh a
bunch of us and I was telling Brody's
friends and I never heard whatever the
[__] Allison Chains and he gave me a a
cassette tape and I got to tell you
something it was like a a recorded
cassette tape he goes take it with you
and I didn't put it on I didn't put it
on for weeks and one day I went on the
road to Portland Oregon it's like a
three-hour drive from Seattle and I put
this [__] cassette on and what I
heard I was blown the [__] away and the
album that he had turned me on to was
this one right here it's called jar of
flies I personally think this is a
[__] Masterpiece okay and don't get
me wrong the one before this sap is
[__] tremendous this is two albums
for one we're not up to sap yet we'll
come back to sap in a few weeks but for
right now we're on [__] jar of flies
I listened to this and I was blown the
[__] away the guitar the guy's voice I
didn't know what the guy's name was you
know I had no [__] notes there was no
liner notes it was just a cassette I was
blown away and I remember listening to
rotten apple but the song that killed me
from this album where [__] my man
Shines on the guitar as I stay away this
is a [__]
tremendous this album is nonstop guys
I'm going to read you the songs on this
album your [__] [__] are going to
pucker do you understand me let me show
you what's on this album right here this
is Allison Chains Lane Staley Jerry
Cantrell Sean Kenny and Mike inz is
tremendous they had additional musicians
but who gives a [__] some guy in a
harmonica big [__] deal all right
written at recordered London Bridge
Studio Seattle September 7th 1993 to
September 14th it took a week to tape
this out the songs on here are you ready
for this [__] okay side one is
this song right here rotten apples then
we got I stay away nutshell no excuses
and whale and wasp for you guys who
don't know
this album is a [__] greatest its
album right that first side will [__]
listen you want to shoot out a [__]
don't do heroin listen to it listen to
it straight then do the heroin later if
you want to jump out of window then you
could jump out of window then side two
is two tremendous songs don't
follow and swing on
this I don't know what else to [__]
tell you guys this album was something
that I put on uh 20 years ago maybe and
I started listening to this album again
when we made the move from California to
New Jersey and it blew me the [__] away
this album this song something from this
album is on my computer every [__]
day something from this album and don't
get me started because the one before
this was sap and the one after this I
think is down in a whole album Dirt so
you better [__] polish your shoes
[__] suckers cuz Alice and chains does
not [__] around I don't know if you have
de music or you have one their albums I
don't give a [__] what album you start
with whether it's uh what is it facelift
was the first album sap is the second
one jar flies jar flies dirt and the
self tile and then the self-title one
this is a [__] lineup of death this
is as strong as arrol Smith's first five
[__] albs so if I was you I get on
[__] uh whatever tonight in order the
album jar of flies look at that little
boy looks like little Eddie Bravo right
there looking at the [__] flies and
you guys remember that's Lee looking at
the Flies and these flies are the ones I
used to get high you know why he wrote
This Album J flies I'm going tell you
why because Jerry Cantrell did a science
project when he was younger I swear to
God he did a science project when he was
younger and he had to keep a a jar of
flies two jars of flies one that you fed
and one that you didn't feed and the one
that you fed they reproduce but they die
because they overcrowding the other on
so he did it and this is why he called
the jar of [__] flies I think the
album cover is [__] brilliant I got
really high One n just that at the album
cover and I was like what the [__] is
this the album is [__] tremendous you
got the insides there rotten apple no
excuses oh my God pissing on their
pictures this is guys if you're not into
Allison Chains get into Allison Chains I
don't care if bleed the freak I don't
give a [__] what you get but if you want
to start with [__] uh jar flies you
wouldn't be doing yourself wrong
[__] this is it this heroin music
music to the [__] Max [__] I
wish I get some number two and write
something like this it'd be [__]
brilliant I love you guys thank you for
watching album of the week the album of
the week is jar flies you bad
[__] stay black have a great
week Uncle Joey loves you see you next
[Music]
week